it's unpopular for men to be seen as
stoic a stoic man is a toxic man in the
minds of Hollywood writers whereas I see
it as like a necessary survival skill
throughout most of human history you
can't have everyone be high strung
emotional idiots who just go to PCS the
moment things start going wrong there
needs to be stoic people who can deal
with problems logically and don't
complain all the time about things
people used to live Hard lives previous
generations would be shocked and
appalled by how easy we have it now we
don't live in that world now and so that
idea of stoicism the stoic man who gets
things done and who doesn't complain
about it that is seen as a toxic relic
of a different time and I think
particularly because the writers that
you have you've either got women now in
Hollywood who are threatened by that or
you have effeminate men who've never
endured hardship who are envious of that
and so either side wants to destroy it
and get rid of it and mock it because
they don't understand it